what's up with a mask the boy check me
out in the bootleg cab podcast man it's
serious honey
yeah podcast we got a special guest in
here my guy representing Vallejo man the
boy yes sir what's good bro man I know
man I'm just out here working man zombie
right now ain't got no sleep man
straight work mode man
um
you I feel like it's been it's been at
least a year year and a half since
you've been back on the show man so
welcome back I appreciate you for having
me again so far you have been putting
out a lot of music this year when we're
used to you dropping so much so I'm only
assuming you got a whole lot of [__]
coming I got a whole lot coming for so a
whole lot of coming yeah cause uh you
were you were putting some high pressure
on 2022 man you did some high pressure
for so I ain't gonna lie it's gonna be a
lot of way more pressure than what I was
applying at 22 for real I'm just getting
started for real my year just getting
started I had a Ralphie the plug on the
show and he went viral because he was
talking about how your album was much
better than Kendrick's album damn
mindless shout out to Ralphie good guy
uh you guys dropped that album on the
same day how do you like because I do
feel like the people who give you
respect are like the people you're like
you would really want respect from but
do you still feel like you're a little
slept on
I mean
I I just put it like this I ain't where
I want to be you family I I ain't
nowhere where I want to be I'ma just
keep working you family time I'm just
one of them for I already believe I
already believe in myself that I wanted
to I just got to put it out there you
feel me put it in a face you can't be
fun to believe that so I ain't gonna lie
2023 like you say I ain't been doing
like I ain't gonna say I've been doing
I've been doing private recording yeah
like I ain't gonna lie my year really
just start starting to get started for
real I'm finna when you drop so much
pressure April 14th album album what's
it called I ain't gonna say album
mixtape project whatever EP okay P seven
songs nice seven songs what's you got a
name for it yup 2K 23. oh I like it all
right 2K 23 man Balling on these man I
ain't gonna lie this might be uh
this this might be my last solo album uh
this year for real you're doing some
collab albums with people uh I got some
but I don't they might they might drop
it I don't really count them for you
know that so when you say your last solo
album so what does that mean probably
just for the year I'm really just
awesome I'm gonna just be dropping but I
probably ain't gonna drop no tape for
real just like singles hey probably just
singles for real just dropping you know
the attention span is so short you feel
me
Just Gonna Keep it lit with some singles
for real what is uh you know we were
just talking a little bit about the
Russell obviously coming out of your
your town
um so many legends that come out of
Vallejo too by the way
um what is it like to kind of see
someone like the Russell kind of take a
different approach to the music industry
obviously he's not really kind of right
now we get so much of the street music
from Vallejo he's kind of given us a
whole different side of the coin I tell
the Russell every time I see him he'll
tell you I call him baby Jesus right
baby Jesus like when we see the wrestle
We Believe type that you really really
like when you walk around this with
angel wings and a halo around this right
yeah when you walk around this see the
goat like he's showing the way yeah and
he's not he's not putting no negativity
in the world like he pushing all
positivity like I tell that like you
you're you're going to heaven for the
show like you got to like you spreading
a good message like he wanna like you
know you know because in the Bible that
they talk about that be spreading God
message yeah he a prophet yeah he one of
them you know have you been to his house
for any of his shows yet yeah
pretty crazy you got the backyard going
crazy it's right in the neighborhood
yeah so and they and they so respectful
and he be on some pay what you want to
like a mug when you're doing like that
like gonna give you 100 for a shirt
right you might have some little low
ballers but you're gonna run into
somebody that's gonna even out yeah it's
gonna even out for sure probably he then
they're getting molding even outfit so I
was gonna say uh how far are you from
compared to where his house is at or is
that kind of like I ain't even invalid
you talking about like where we from
though like yeah where you from yeah
like we from around the corner for sure
yeah like we both in the north the north
little hell is small that [__] like
really like it is very small it's as
small as an island for yeah like this
Island's bigger than Vallejo
um you obviously have been somebody who
tapped in with this what's going on in
Stockton because Stockton's kind of on
fire right now man
kind of the base cousin a little bit you
know yeah yeah a lot of people who
aren't from the bay lump Sacramento
Stockton and the bay all is one even
though they're not I don't know
um you worked with young sloby before he
passed away talk about your guys's
relationship obviously rest in peace to
him but you know that was a big loss for
Stockton
RPM Mary since I tapped in with him like
you think because he's just been genuine
for that's my like I call that like we
just talk on some other than not even on
no music for real like he'll come pull
up on me you feel me uh I I line little
plays up from for him to go get this so
you send me all type of little asthma
[Music]
a lot of them cool do you ever do like
shows in Stockton uh I did a show in
Stockton before probably an SOB shot
I probably did a solo show like not too
long ago but
that'd be so much going on I wouldn't
even remember you've been a part of some
crazy [__] man for sure I probably the
last time I probably did this on
Stockton probably like a year or two ago
I don't remember being out there but I
know I did a couple shows out there for
sure yo what was it like being a part of
the Black Panther soundtrack because
that kind of was a moment yeah
Kendrick was on that record too yeah
that's a big deal now first of all not a
lot of people these days sharing records
with Kendrick and that's one of the
biggest movies of all time so that's my
biggest song to this day that's going
like double platinum in them but just
the song itself and they ain't got no
videos no video nothing I feel like that
was kind of like the last hurray for SOB
kinda yeah that was like our biggest I
feel like after that is when it kind of
started uh yeah man a lot of this
started happening man behind the scenes
you know how that go man just some more
brothers fighting behind the scenes like
we brothers and we was young
like but what was that moment like for
you like just kind of knowing you met
you're making it onto a Marvel movie
soundtrack and and Kendrick's hopping on
the record I ain't gonna lie when we
first got in the studio we got on that
like
I really ain't think it was gonna really
come out he's like yep we at least got
the chance to be in the studio with that
and give us what oh you guys are in the
studio with him hey we got the so this
really just had the mindset like at
least we got up in the studio and got
the chance to defend me so that what we
got for real you fan and it's a banger
but when that came out
I heard the uh Black Panther came out
but we just ain't really think you sent
me I was on there so I really didn't
even check like I was just calling like
yo we made the Black Panther soundtrack
y'all going crazy your first one stupid
I'm like hell nah I'm in the studio at
the time too recording I go straight to
the soundtrack I listen to that
the way you put the little pause on my I
was like oh I ain't gonna lie like that
then they're like Goosebumps right you
feel me the way that hit it with the the
boy you feel me then change the tempo
for like four bars like I ain't gonna
lie that [__] I'm feeling like a
champion you know like when you growing
up a guy you you in sports you went in
trophies and [__] when I was playing
sports like online really win too many
trophies right like I was really a
Streetball player I wouldn't really you
found me one of the ones really really
on the court so you family like that
like that's a trophy for me listen do
you want to win some money gotta stop
the interview but listen there's so many
opportunities to gamble to bet on your
favorite sports to make Sports more
interesting NFL season is over but it's
all good because the opportunities to
win are just getting started yeah look
there's so many things you can do we're
talking about NCAA NBA NHL UFC boxing
there's Blackjack tournaments so much
money to get in on and check this out
out y'all if you sign up right now using
the promo code bootleg do it right now
you can get a welcome bonus up to a
thousand dollars plus you're gonna get a
free 150
000 March Madness bracket contest entry
that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
that could give you two hundred dollars
you put in a thousand they'll give you
another thousand right look right now go
to mybookie.ag sign up use that promo
code March Madness is upon us so much
great Sports just NBA season playoffs
are on the way man you could like
literally put together some crazy props
like uh I don't know over under on a
player that you like scoring you could
do a future on the MVP do you think
jokic is going to win it you think Joel
embiid's Gonna Win It Whatever It Is get
in on the action right now mybookie.ag
with that promo code bootleg when you
sign up get that free deposit bonus all
right bet any anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie also shout out to our
family at hardean Harding Las Vegas Yes
you see him I was just there in Vegas
yesterday this is the best place I've
ever been to in terms of dispensaries
I've been to probably hundreds of these
things and the experience at hardean is
like nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas do you ever because I
saw uh Lil G just got sentenced to some
serious prison time
um and we think kind of like
everybody kind of went their own way
when it came to the group it feels like
you're kind of the one guy who's kind of
cut through and like been able to really
be consistent and really kind of show
improve as a solo artist
um a shout out to Young Teo he's up you
know he's obviously has some dope solo
[__] too but for you like uh
not knowing your personal relationship
with these guys anymore but do you tap
in with somebody like Lil G if he you
know gets he has to go sit down for 20
years like just on somebody like you
said some brothership or is that
relationship kind of a rap
slimming my brother
and that's it it's let me my brother
that's fair who's gonna be on the EP
uh [__] really just Kaylin for real for
real for real I can't wait to hear that
yeah Mama's you know I'm trying to push
that I'm trying to push that one uh I'm
trying to push that one sound man I'm
trying to gain my my lady fan base you
family so he's on the hook uh yeah for
sure yes sir was there something you
guys got in the studio together on yeah
yep I called that [__] that [__]
pulled up laid that [__] down lay my
[__] down boom classic it's one of them
ones too on my mama yo speak to me
because uh Mac Dre is from Vallejo and
obviously you know one of the more
celebrated artists to come out of the
bay especially if you're from the bay
did you grow up listening to Mac Dre
were you or was he I mean that was kind
of like past your generation a bit like
was that something that you just kind of
had to go back
you feel me like
his music was always around like of
course like [__] knew like all the all
the big [__] like even like even like
the big the song that was like big in
the streets like [__] knew mostly of
them like most of that [__] though like
I really had to go back and go you see
me dig do my own little researching for
real when I was young like I was really
into [__] like
like I was really into like the
mainstream [__] like Lil Wayne Like of
course a young [__] at that time like
Soulja Boy like I had to really do my
own digging I knew the main [__] though
but like to hear him on his gangster
[__] like when he first came out oh yeah
like early [__] yeah yeah I had to go do
my own research for sure I do feel like
you guys kind of influenced a generation
of
I feel like
SOB y'all probably don't get as a group
the credit you deserve in terms of you
guys influenced a lot of La guys yeah
for so I feel like a lot of like how you
guys are rapping the flow y'all had like
kind of the slightly offbeat [__] like I
feel like you guys kind of and this can
be said about the Bay Area in general
with a lot of [__] that happens
you guys influence a lot of [__] but
don't necessarily get the credit for the
influence that you guys have on hip hop
even La hip-hop do you guys did you guys
notice that like happening because you
guys are the hottest [__] moving and a
lot of people in La started to pop up
that in my opinion sounded a lot like
what you guys are doing yeah did you
notice that yeah for so you know how
that [__] go like we don't really you
know how that [__] go like we don't
really get no we don't get credit for a
lot of [__] but you feel me like [__]
not gonna hit the scene cry about it and
pout for real I mean like it is what it
is at the end of the day though a lot of
[__] that you feel me a lot of [__]
I run into like they're paying [__]
homage like when they see a [__] but
like [__] probably not just gonna ain't
nobody's gonna want to put it out there
like oh [__] I ain't gonna lie
I I relieve like [__] really base my
flow off the young [__] like we young
[__] like maybe if we was like
some OG's or something in the game like
[__] it'd be easier to pay
homage to be like oh I really been grew
up listening young [__] you feel me
don't know about not too many
[__] want to give a young [__]
too much credit you feel me they think a
young [__] big-headed oh they don't
want to give a a young [__] that much
juice that much power but [__] don't
be you feeling me like [__] be on some
humble [__] [__] not really tripping
off that [__] like it is what it is like
like I think of you guys and I think
like Shoreline Mafia had like a lot of
Sons like he's kind of yeah so you gotta
remember like one [__] might
copy us and then the [__] that
copied us a [__] might have
copied them Mighty not even not listen
to our [__] starting me like it's just
it's just so much recycled [__] going on
you don't know who a [__] really
getting [__] from like we started a lot
of [__] but like a lot of [__] got
recycled like you feel me like
[__] get it's like lost files
like [__] don't know where they
got this and that from right it's all
good though like I'm glad to see that
[__] credit away for everybody
to eat for real cause a lot of the young
[__] scene was dead it wasn't no young
[__] really rapping for real like we
taught young [__] how to talk [__] you
feel me just be free you feel me uh
speaking mind it's a lot of cappers up
on this [__] too that you they making
no way though you feel me congratulate
them boys
feeding a lot of young [__] off the
wave and a [__] started but I
ain't gonna say [__] we all
started this [__] as a group but right
you feel me like they ain't tripping out
that [__] let them boys go crazy what's
up guys hey shout out to our family at
uh blue shoe man listen I know we always
are getting feedback about our Bluetooth
interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's their
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just dropped
the mint chewable same active ingredient
as Levitra that's right so what you need
to do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the odd Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff oddsocksofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will save 20 off at checkout try the
Odd Socks Basics if you're one of those
guys who wears other plain white branded
socks plain black socks I promise you go
with the odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they're just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro Stand Down be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview how are
you feeling about the younger generation
in the bay right now who are some of the
young guys that you're [__] with that
are kind of obviously coming up there's
some young [__] going crazy ebk cam
going crazy from Stockton yeah DB dude
from Zach's dope oh yeah DB about a bag
you going crazy a young [__] uh mods
for real he going crazy
who the [__] else uh my young [__]
going crazy little buddy Joe ski a
little Sculpey baby brothers all the GBS
who else uh they they are from Vallejo
too
oh who was going crazy Fredo bags this
ain't gonna last a lot of young [__]
going crazy it's really a young [__]
world right now Tula I can't even keep
up with who all really going crazy but
shout out all them boys like are you
would you you said solo projects early
does that mean you got any collab [__]
coming or would you drop like a whole
tape with somebody or a whole EP with an
artist
uh yeah I probably I'll probably end up
releasing one or two of them by the end
of the year well who I ain't gonna say
all that and you feel me it's some [__]
in the works I gotta [__] I got some
[__] I got some [__] anybody from is it
from the bay or outside of the Bay
[Music]
it had me on my private [__]
and we [__] around do some [__] for so
we got to do some [__] like molding just
one song like we got to do a couple like
for the culture for sure man for sure
um okay so we got a April 12th you said
uh April 14th April 14th NBA 2K 23
the EP Kayla for real for real on it
yeah anything else you got working on
brother
man [__] really [__] just working like
I'm just I'm just going I'm just going
like it ain't no it ain't no stop to
this [__] like I'm really not I'm really
just not focused on dropping tapes and
EPS like I'ma just you feel me just drop
songs here and there you know let me see
how that [__] play out one time
just worry about not getting bipped out
in the bay because it's hot outside do
you feel like it's finally starting to
because I feel like during the pandemic
like at least the city got like way
worse do you feel like it's like
starting to get a little bit better
and for people who don't know Vallejo is
not close to San Francisco it's a
mission it's what about 45 minutes yeah
like 45 like catch and then there would
be an hour on a bad day for sure yeah
for sure but like I do feel like the bay
kind of got pretty crazy in terms of
just like
lawlessness homeless people [__]
[__] running into CVS's and
coming up as long as it was under a
thousand dollars do you feel like it's
getting like a little better
is it starting to get a little
nah not really it's just it's a lot of
[__] going on like that don't get posted
like right I I'll be like me and my
[__] like we be on the uh it's like a
little app it let you know everything
that's going on yeah that [__] like it's
hella [__] that be going on but it don't
hit the news like you feel that [__] is
like that [__] that [__] down there like
is it's regular out there like you just
you get alerts hey like it'd be so much
crazy [__] out there like when that [__]
do get posted like they hit the ground
everybody laughing about it like that
[__] mainly like it's just regular
though well listen man 2K 23 April 14th
make sure you look out for that new
music all the rest of the year
the boy appreciate you brother my [__]
appreciate you for having me yes sir on
the game